we've got Nick Foles on the phone line
he is the quarterback of the four and
one Philadelphia Eagles getting set to
take on the New York Giants on Sunday
Night Football in front of the entire
country and he's joining me on the phone
line right now how are you Nick I'm
doing great it's got out of practice and
about to do some recovery stuff what is
recovery stuff what is it oh that's just
making sure you get a protein in eat
some lunch iced down in the cold lots of
great things you get to party right yeah
I know you can't see right now but I'm
in a cold tub myself Nick right now
see you're being very productive
multitask while I'm in recovery I'm in
recovery from the very very long first
hour of this program that's you know how
would you rate your performance so far
this season Nick I mean as a team we're
playing well reform one as a performance
for me I want to get better rating on a
scale I don't know I'm not big on that I
just know that I want to improve on
different things protecting the ball
more be more accurate completing more
passes and as a offense I want us to
throw more points and that's my goal and
that's what we work towards every week
what is your relationship with Chip
Kelly how and take walk me through I
guess the communication process between
the two of you as you go through a work
week until the big week like this one I
have a great relationship ever since
he's I mean I was going back to college
we played against them every single year
and I got to know him a little bit and
then just let him be in my head coach
it's been great I'm just just philosophy
on things and then throughout the work
week as we go to practice we'll talk
about things as the plays develop and
when we're you know just casual it's not
like we overdo it it's a natural
relationship where you go to work and
he's my head coach now I'm gonna go out
there and play for him the the
philosophy which was brought up by
Albert Breer of NFL Network we had on
earlier that defensive coordinators were
able to dissect what you guys did last
year and might be having more success
this year against you because of that
what adjustments have has
have been made in the Chip Kelly offense
this year different from last that you
can let us in on what is the offense I
mean you always I mean the NFL there's a
lot of talent especially on the
defensive side of the ball with the de
coordinators and all their defensive
schemes all the different looks so as
often she has to give different look at
the motion yet the shifts you have to do
things to disguise concepts and that's
what everybody does and then defensively
people are they have a lot more
philmont's now so they're gonna they're
going to try to change things up on us
on the run when we do our simple taxes
and that's where we just have to really
over you know communicate during the
week and then play that game with your
mind well what if they go to this would
they haven't shown this or what if they
do that and just make sure when we get
to a game we have an answer so what what
are your keys against the Giants this
week in your estimation I mean the key
to get the Giants I mean it's every week
we got to play team football we got to
play well on all sides of the ball on
our defensive special teams is really
been playing well offenses getting
things going we lean on each other we
play as a group and through the course
of a football game you're gonna face
adversity and I think the big strength
of our team is we have to we stick
together we're brothers in there and
we're going to lean on each other if
offense is struggling we know the
defense is gonna go in there and pick us
up with defenses you know strong they
know the offense and go special teams is
gonna be a spark and that's why this
team so great is we lean on each other
in terms of leaning on each other and
picking each other up I'm sure you know
obviously LeSean McCoy I've interviewed
him before he's a very confident guy
he's one of the best most dynamic
players in the National Football League
and the numbers do not support that this
year what what have you done in order to
keep him active and trying to get him
more rush yards for the lack of a better
phrase there's not much left to do to
keep him active he's going to continue
to work I know the son he wants to
continue to grow and be great so he
comes to work every day like everyone
else the work to get better and then the
thing is you have to keep working
through I'll try to keep grinding our
lines going against different looks just
picking it up when the running back to
this being hit it and this is
everybody's gonna make a big deal we
have to continue to grow I mean I got
this force the guys on the defensive
side of the ball are very talented and
they have great coaches themselves so we
just have to continue to work and when
we when it comes to game time with a
you on all cylinders it really is as
simple as that Nick at this point last
year you were just coming off of a win
over the Giants 197 yards passing two
touchdowns but it was still in many
people's minds Michael Vick's team
moving forward in the Chip Kelly
administration but now this is clearly
your team you are the starting
quarterback of the Philadelphia Eagles
period end of story
what's this ride have been like for you
Nick
definitely things changed I mean I think
it's more so with in the locker room you
just you develop more of a relationship
with the guys around them longer you get
more rest with them you're in the locker
room you're in the workouts I think the
big thing with the changes is you do a
lot more media you do a lot more of
those things where you try to you try to
make sure you're doing you yes I do
certain obligations but then I want to
make sure all my energy is going in my
team and going into that and personally
my personality has not changed it's just
other things around you that yes there's
no doubt when you're playing the game
you play the game like you always do
well you you know I tried you know I've
always been up for interviewing you I
didn't need to wait till you were Nick
Foles the starter right I'm not part of
that paparazzi Nick aware that right I'm
aware that okay just want to make sure
what so you mentioned how you your new
chip back in college what was it like
after Arizona beat Oregon this past most
recent man I was really proud of my
Wildcats
I wore my Arizona shirt as I always do I
wear it proudly but I wore with my chest
out a little bit more that day because I
was proud of him we have a lot of
warding guys here so no he do they were
they weren't very talkative towards me
that's a after the game so it gives a
good feeling uh shoes our guys are
looking good number 10 many people so
I'm excited for the Wildcats I know in
pac-12 football doesn't really go mean
you're you're in the East Coast there
and you know about the East Coast bias
in the media Nick people think pac-12
where we used to be packed ten obviously
little soft that it's not the same it's
not the SEC but I don't know about that
Nick now there's a good conference is a
in fact those their stuff teams
basketball football whatever softball
volleyball whatever story you want to go
there to create athletes over there
definitely different athletes as you go
through the United States you know the
SPP certain tax rolls different big 12
whatever maybe ACC but earlier there's
some talent over there in the pac-12 in
it I think it's gonna continue to show
throughout the year last question for
you Nick you are the first quarterback
to phone into the Rich Eisen show my
show started just Monday you're the
first quarterback in the National
Football League you're the first guy to
do so and you're the first one who's
going to be subsequently playing in
front of the entire country is there
something that I can create with you
after say you have a successful play or
even a touchdown if you're so lucky to
to sort of tap your helmet or something
that's just a sign for me that we're on
the same page I mean Maurice jones-drew
has done touchdown celebrations before
is there any way I could set something
up right here right now with you Nick I
can't answer to tug on your ear because
you're wearing a helmet but you know
what I'm you you see where I'm going I
see where you're going nothing else to
top my head I mean I think you're
storing a touchdown to know that this
conversation I was thinking about their
own touchdowns and it started you know
part of it was here okay so if you know
well yeah I mean it's a verbal
commitment it's a verbal commitment I
give you a vertical commit I can't write
anything down yet the fact the paper
over something sure I mean if you have
people I have people we can we can
arrange that we just touch just I don't
know we could just you could just pound
your chest just just just tap just tap
their number but good top your number
just tap your number on the front of
your chest and I know that's for me and
the show
alright Nick thanks very much I
appreciate that I'm honored no no and me
too
thank you so much that's Nick Foles of
the Philadelphia Eagles of four and one
Eagles calling in on the Rich Eisen show